well i'm here at the devil's summit and
had formal meetings and conversations of
course one of the big topics the
discussion here is how do we create a
safer banking system and what is great a
lot of interest is what the pros in the
United States Obama has said about both
limiting some of the riskiest activities
that retail banks have to take like
large scale proprietary trading and also
looking at the idea going forward of a
banking levy to better protect taxpayers
that are against the consequences of
banks getting into trouble now both
these ideas are ideas that myself and
the British Conservative Party are very
interested in we'd like to see them done
internationally this is an international
banking industry and talking to people
here at Davos both officials and
politicians you get the sense that there
is one level support this it's a big
challenge how do we have successful
financial services that are poised many
thousands of people in Britain make sure
bring and remains a great center of
global financial services while at the
same time protecting appreciated a and
making sure that the banking system is
serving its customers instead of serving
the businesses and hos that's been on
his credit so lots of interesting
discussions I feel that what the ghans
British Conservative Party and sent out
is the right direction it's certainly
with the mainstream of thinking yeah and
I looked all doing over one more day
left seeing what people have to say
those